l'arrivée de l'hiver est un souci de
plus à gérer en Ukraine les
infrastructures énergétiques sont
lourdement endommagées par les frappes
russes d'après le représentant de
l'organisation mondial de la santé qui
est aujourd'hui en Ukraine la vie de
millions de civils est menacée pour
faire simple dit-il cet hiver sera une
question de survie on l'écoute il était
au micro d'Elizabeth Alain un peu plus
tôt
il y a une grande difficulté avec
l'accès aux populations donc les zones
occupées mais même dans les territoires
récemment libérés par exemple il y a
plus de soins de santé
malheureusement aussi un grand problème
avec les médecins les infirmières mais
depuis le 10 octobre
environ 5 50% de l'infrastructure civile
d'énergie est détruit alors là ça
poserait une menace vitale pour des
millions des Ukrainiens
et aussi pour les hôpitaux qui ne
peuvent pas fonctionner sont et accepter
pas de maltraités sont couveuses c'est
quelque chose qu'on doit maintenant
anticiper au plus tôt et au plus fort de
nos moyens avant l'hiver voilà justement